Alhamdulillah. Continuing
[Silence]
in the fifth chapter of
authored by
the chapter of
vigilance of Allah's observation
We had arrived and began yesterday
the sixth narration, the narration of
with regarding the three individuals
that Allah chose to test from amongst
bi.
So he said,
that three individuals from amongst Ben
is one a leper, the other a bald man and
the third a blind man whom Allah wished
to test. And so he sent to them an
angel.
and this angel not only
was the cause for them to be healed
from their respective illness, but each
of them as well was given what he most
desired or the beginnings of what he
most desired with respect to wealth. So
the
leper was asked, "What would you
desire?" the most. He said to have a
nice complexion, clear skin,
and that he asked for camels. And so
he was given a pregnant she camel and
his skin was cured. And the same with
the bold man only he asked for cows and
he was given
a
pregnant
cow.
And the third
was cured of his blindness and asked for
sheep.
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said
foreign.
[Silence]
And so time passed and each one of them
was given
a succession
of wealth.
The she camel had a baby and from the
babies
it continued to breed. He continued to
breed this camel. The other continued to
breed his cattle. The other continued to
breed his sheep until ultimately each
had a valley's fill of camels or cattle
or sheep. So just based on this
information here, how much time would
have probably elapsed
for a person to go from one camel,
one pregnant camel to an entire valleys
filled of pregnant camels or or camels,
years, maybe even decades, right? We're
talking about he continued to have
he continued to have success through
the years.
This is
this person was able to amass
generational wealth
from one camel,
from one cow, from one sheep, enough to
fill an entire valley. We're speaking
about probably at least years, most
likely decades,
right? But the test wasn't over. All
this was part of the test, right? All of
those decades
were part of the test. They were still
being tested for that time.
And so
the test wasn't just the end.
A lot of times we get
we get
hyperfocused on the end of the
narration. Those of us who have heard
this narration before, it's a well-known
narration.
We get hyperfocused on the conclusion.
However, in truth, the test began from
that faithful day. And the test began
with that one camel, with that one cow,
with that one sheep. And the test
continued throughout those years.
Is there we mentioned yesterday that the
first two when they were asked for
something, they wanted something to make
them acceptable to others.
Whereas the third man asked for
something to make him be able to
function amongst others. Very big
difference.
Number two,
the first two did not reference Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala at all.
The third one when he was asked if you
could have anything, he said, I wish
that Allah would do this, would restore
my vision for me.
And so just on that based on that alone
we see that they were then given wealth
they were then given health.
The question here is
if somebody is
suffering from
problems of the heart. When I say when
we say heart problems, we're speaking
about
the heart, the soul, the the spiritual
heart.
And when a person is suffering from a
lack of morals, suffering from a lack of
connectivity or fear of Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
if someone is just lacking in that
department in general, as a matter of
fact, most problems, most problems,
does money help those problems?
No. There are you can count them on
your hands.
The amount of issues that can be
remedied with money.
Most problems human beings have is not
an issue of money. And this doesn't
invalidate the value of money because
those things that money does help are
really big things. They're really big
parts of our lives.
But having sudden immense wealth,
sudden health after illness, this is
rarely good for a person who was already
sick. Doesn't just fix the problems.
Problems are far more complex than
that. As we'll see in this narration,
the prophet sallall.aii Wasam says,
"Then the angel came back to the leper
who's no longer a leper by Allah's
miracle.
And he came to him in his image
and in his circumstance
that he was found in decades earlier,
that the angel found him in decades
earlier.
Foreign
[Silence]
He says, "And then after each of them
had amassed this huge amount of wealth,
the angel came to the first man who was
previously a leper, he came to him and
notice how the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam, he didn't say he came to the
man who used to be a leper."
He said to him, "He came to the leper."
Now, this could be for one of two
reasons. Either because that's the only
introduction we've had of this man. So,
that's become his name or his title for
us as far as this story is concerned. or
because while this man
superficially was healed, he was always
very sick and he still continued to be
sick. Even after the physical sickness
went away, even after the physical
poverty went away, he was still poor, he
was still sick. That was just the
superficial.
And so he came to that man, the angel
came to him in the form of a leper who
was very poor and had zero connections.
The same exact situation he was before.
And he said to him, I am a very poor man
and I am traveling and I have gotten cut
off from my destination.
All ropes have been severed.
for me and I have no way of getting home
except by Allah and then by you through
you. So I ask you by the one who has
given you such beautiful skin
and the one who has given you such a
beautiful com flawless complexion and
the one who has given you all of this
wealth.
one camel
so that I can get back to where I came
from in my travels.
Notice how Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
gives you the answers to the test as the
test is being given. He didn't just let
him forget. No, no, no. There's no
excuse here. He's reminded you of
everything. And those words, I'm sure,
cut a scalpel to the core of his
heart because he remembers exactly.
Everyone else sees this man. He looks in
the mirror and sees that poor leper that
nobody wanted to touch or get close to
or talk to or speak to or allow into
their gatherings. The one who had zero
say in anything. And now overnight
everybody is saying, "Man, this is the
guy." And he started to believe his own
hype. But when this angel came back, he
took him right back to where he started.
Let's see if he's grown. And so he asked
him this. And what was the man's
response? He said,
he said, "I've just got too many
responsibilities.
just can't can't afford this one camel.
I too many responsibilities. Sorry.
Every one of these camels is spoken for.
Can't muster. Can't can't spare not even
one.
So the man then said,
He said, "It's as if I know you from
somewhere. I seem to recognize you.
Weren't you a leper
and then, you know, was well known that
you got cured and you were very poor and
then you became rich." You know,
everybody knows that story. He wouldn't
even admit that. What does he say? He
says,
So he says as if I know you weren't
weren't you that guy? He said no I have
this I have I actually inherited this
wealth
from my grand my my forefathers. This
wealth has always been in our family.
We've always been wealthy. He got me
confused with someone else. It's not me.
He wouldn't even admit
that that's where he came from. Now,
what is the point of this narration?
Many people who read or have heard this
narration, they get sidetracked by
the greatest crime committed by this
man. This is this is a criminal here. We
are dealing with an ungrateful criminal.
However, the question is,
what is the greatest crime
that he is guilty of thus far?
[Arabic recitation]
is not ascribing his fortune to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. And I don't mean in
a superficial way.
I don't mean in a superficial way. in a
superficial way. Everybody does that.
Oh, I'm so blessed. Oh, God has blessed
me. Everyone, even Kufo,
everyone knows exactly what to say
because they, you know, they know
what's acceptable and what's
unacceptable. However,
if you listen closely,
even if they say Allah, even if they say
God, even if they use words blessed
and so forth, and they're hard of
hearts, and when you really sit down
with them,
you'll listen to their their war
stories,
their stories of heroism.
I'm so smart. I'm so clever. No one
could have done what I've done. I'm
fantastic.
I did this and I did that and I know
this and I know that. And they carry
around the arrogance of Pharaoh himself
in their heart. Even if they use the
right buzzwords,
words mean nothing if they don't match
what's in a person's heart.
They mean nothing.
If you were to go back and and and read
in the Quran who has made some of the
greatest proclamations
in the Quran, the most greatest
proclamations in the Quran, it is the
hypocrites. Their proclamations are
second to none.
If you die, we die. We're here with you.
If you go, we go. If you stay, we stay.
You are the messenger of Allah. The
greatest proclamations of all
in the Quran are made by criminals and
are made by hypocrites.
proclamations of loyalty, proclamations
of dutifulness, etc.
However, the greatest actions, no,
greatest actions are for the believers.
And so it's not just an issue of Allah
gave me this. No. If a person really
believes Allah gave them this, not only
would it reflect itself in their
words, not just the proclamations and
the subtlety of their words, the way
that their words are put together.
And we'll give an example of that
tomorrow inshallah
of a real life example of someone who is
grateful to Allah truly and one who is
feigning gratefulness
from the Quran.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Give it
a whirl.
[Arabic recitation]